whether you like it or not
you're now a superhero
very good i'm just trying to show you no
i'm done i'm shown i did not go to law
school to become a vigilante
[Applause]
our universe is on the edge of a
precipice all right let's do this
who the hell are you
that name better not stick
attorney at law only on disney plus
because being a superhero is a trial by
fire
bruce i'm not gonna be a superhero what
else you're gonna do as a hulk
[Applause]
lawyer
we just started a superhuman law
division and i want the she-hulk to be
the face-off
we do things by the book the book of his
chanting the book of american
uh loss
[Music]
being a hulk asks for balance
[Music]
it's easy
little punk
so i'm clearly nailing it at all these
things when am i ever going to use this
as a lawyer jen when you have powers
like this it's like putting a target on
your back in the backs of all the people
you care about oh cool yet another way
my life is run thanks bruce all right
all i've been doing is showing you the
downsides of being a hulk but there are
a few upsides
our bodies metabolize alcohol at an
incredibly fast rate
which means
that we can drink so much and not get
drunk
all buzz no barf
just good
you